[Music]
i am going to kill a man
i'm going crazy i don't know where he
lives baby
i've lost my mind i don't know his name
but i'm going to find him
i'm george and kill him
nice to meet you nice to meet you too
you've got a secret i wish i knew what
it was i know what you're doing and it's
got to stop
i just like taking risks how big
i am going to kill a man the only thing
i don't know
is how let the games begin
[Music]
by the end of 2022 corncob tv won't be
available on your cable menu
that means you won't be able to see some
of your favorite tv shows
including
[Music]
never let the party die
i don't know if you're allowed to do
that
i cannot talk about it without crying
here we go oh everybody clap so he's got
to come up
come see what happened you gotta come
gotta come up
[Music]
you never told me your old grandpa used
to be a huge piece of [ __ ]
people can change can you believe it
let's do try and keep the comments and
questions related to the ghost tour okay
any of these little [ __ ] ever pop out
of the [ __ ] wall
[Music]
talk about abduction someone affected
all the fun from this date
i'm telling you that i am you don't even
give me any crap i don't want that
this is gonna be so fun why
hey hold that door hold that door all
that door
[Music]
you want to talk about it
[Music]
every night i have the same nightmare
that day that was hell
i remember people screaming
what's going on they get pit and then
they turn
you watch it spread
and spread
[Music]
it's terrifying leon
it's got to be another outbreak i gotta
go
don't do anything stupid
raccoon city was the beginning we can't
let what happens they buried
[Music]
if we went public with this
we could expose a conspiracy i can't get
anyone to go on record about outbreak
sorry i don't know what to tell you
[Applause]
we need to show the world that we are a
strong nation capable of protecting the
interests of the free world
we must be the source of hope to those
who seek freedom
we cannot allow anyone to interfere with
peace and prosperity
what are you here for that's classified
you know where the root of terror comes
from
starts with fear
i will show you
our group of friends have known each
other since we were babies
we have trust
[Music]
in history we own this school
[Music]
he waits for the light she's not from
here
hey how would you like to come hang with
us tonight
too many joy rides and daddy's jaguar
too many white lies and white lines
super rich kids with nothing but loose
ends super rich kids with nothing but
fake
friends she is a stranger
who has found yourself in your friend
group with your boyfriend
i promised i would stay away from any
drama
[Music]
did you miss me i know i've missed you
gossip girl an anonymous instagram
account that
spies on our students
this just in there's a big secret
amongst the ruling class at constance
biller
why is gossip grown up to get us i'm not
just known
i'm influential and i can't have that
taken away from me
privilege and power will always win in
the end
something's different in a good way in
the best way
[Music]
i cannot die in jail you are a year
older than me
you have lived
senior year [ __ ] this is gonna be
crazy fire
like hanukkah rise up let's get it let's
get it
clean hands clean slate fresh start
wake up let's get it let's get it
between luna between
class between studying for the lsats i
barely have time to go to the bathroom
let alone find
a babysitter i don't think i can do this
i'm a failure on not one but two
continents
why can't you just be honest with me i
don't know what you're complaining about
you're not the one handcuffed to a chair
you put my degree and possibly my entire
career
in jeopardy if anybody should have
called out zoe's boss should have been
you and what you should be doing is
keeping my girl's name out your mouth i
didn't think it could get much worse
but this time you have truly
outdone yourself
damn it my clean slate is dirty already
when i see the news of all these black
men dying all i could do is think about
how i'm just like them
[Music]
martin said that riots are the language
of the unheard
looks like aaron's been serving you the
d and that knowledge can i get an olay
olay baby anyone else olay
[Music]
yeah no we're really not trying to be
around you like that
grown-ish new episodes july 8th on
freeform
and next day on hulu
it'd be nice to be in bed with someone
at night other than my pilot [ __ ]
boyfriend
what kind of [ __ ] boyfriend just like
the pile of [ __ ] on the other side of my
bed
where a person should be oh come on mate
just click it off your bed
it'll be nice to have a reason to clear
it off
my boss wants me to start a teaching
business with him anya this is huge
i am no but i mean it might be too big
shut up i'm a brilliant teacher the
students love you what does my face look
like
crazy very funny mo and the parents love
you hi eddie anne
we can't tell anyone here until we have
it set up wow so many secrets what do
you mean
uh life james
i'll be home in two weeks and then we're
getting married sure the uh little
baby me what are you gonna do with that
oh i might open up the stitching at the
back and
oh brother no i wish i was there
strangely you're planning on sleeping
one of your clients
it's not the best move i really like him
showing up you need to pop the horny do
a little dance
dance it's like britain's got talent
don't make me laugh but also
well done for knowing that cultural
reference
[Music]
i want us to be friends i've actually
started dating someone oh
who great who that's great you have to
show
in life if you're either in or you're
out and i'm
i'm out in i'm in
we're all just out here trying aren't we
and sometimes
what you want to do honestly oh
[Music]
i really worry about you getting carried
away showing up
cop on carried away
i don't think i've ever heard so many
jesuses yeah sorry to talk about my ex
in bed
[Music]
i love you do you love me goodbye i love
you do you love me no
do you love me love you bye
the goal is to disappear behind our
masks
as pleasant interchangeable helpers it's
tropical kabuki
hello happy to be here we're on our
honeymoon you're such
valued guests welcome to the white lotus
are they baby nicole they're [ __ ]
huge i haven't seen them in a while
it's cancer swole balls did say biopsy
or balls dad
not yet surprised
am i interrupting i know it's only your
honeymoon
oh my god look at her face rachel you
were such a beautiful bride
but also very pale but now you have a
little more color and it looks great
thanks you are so
talented do you really know what you're
doing
you think you could have dinner with me
at the hotel tonight um
i get off at seven yeah that's good i
mean like a couple minutes after seven
at the
at the restaurant sounds great
being a young man this time right now
can't be easy
why because we can't harass girls
anymore no
well he thinks i'm an [ __ ]
were you an [ __ ] i guess i'm just
wondering what uh
you might be able to do for us to make
us feel better no i was actually trying
to not be an [ __ ]
that you failed
where were you i just walked around
[Music]
please enjoy
belinda is the best good i'll make an
appointment if she's not booked with me
sometimes just watching them eat every
night makes me want to
gouge my eyes out
what belinda want is to speak to your
boss
[ __ ] this place i don't think it's the
most romantic hotel in hawaii do you
it's perfectly fine but are you finding
it very romantic okay
[Music]
paxton guys how can you be so sure when
you're old and on your deathbed
whose naked body do you want to be
picturing wouldn't i be thinking about
my kids and
grandkids and stuff no that's a mess
this is my last chance for an american
high school boyfriend good morning ben
good morning paxton that's why i have to
figure out my boy's situation stat
what's the alternative you just date two
guys until you move to india
so you're saying i should just have two
boyfriends definitely not
oh my god i have two boyfriends
i'm on a whole another level ben gets my
super brainy side
level paxton gets my mega horny side
level you
kissing your father's ashes have barely
begun to drift out to sea i just got
overcome with emotion what are you gonna
do at my funeral just have sex on top of
my grave
it braids a closed casket pay attention
eyes on me
everybody we have a new student what's
up
another indian girl who's prettier
cooler
davey you're holding that pen like a
knife again
i'll really davey this one up do you
think i'm crazy
you never take no for an answer you
never let anyone get in the way of what
you want
pay attention i'm a changed woman i'm as
chill
as a
[Music]
my mom doesn't tell me how to live my
life megan's stallion does
hey man [ __ ]
[Music]
good morning i'm dr christopher dunch
[Music]
today we're going to be operating on
rose keller patient presented with
severe back pain diagnosed as a
herniated disc
it is important we are in and out with
as little fanfare as possible
so mouth shut ears open let's begin
hey doctor i heard you came across some
of christopher dunches surgeries
sir there's a lot of bleeding focus on
your job
how is the patient perfect there's a
hemorrhage here you need to fix it
so there were no complications i don't
have complications
i can't make sense of this it's like he
knew what he was supposed to do
then he did the exact opposite i could
have told you the guy was a hat
what did he do dorothy burke walked in
all on her own and now she's brain dead
today we'll be minimally invasive and
turned him into a quadriplegic
work ethic was second to none ted bundy
was a good worker too
we all make mistakes but not you no man
dutch has two deaths texas has executed
people from less
all due respect dr kirby you don't
understand the law
you don't understand who we're after
dunch is never going to stop
on his own you have to protect the
public and suspend his license
my patients mean everything to me and
the longer i'm here the longer they're
in pain
you hurt these people you saw what he
did to them
i swear i will make sure this never
happens to anyone else
if you take my license in texas there's
an entire world out there
the system is broken i have a suggestion
it's a bit extreme
he's either the most incompetent surgeon
i've ever crossed
paths with or he's a sociopath
it's true what they say good friends
make you laugh a little louder
and make life a hell of a lot better but
being a good friend
it's all a big balancing act this is my
new
nigel hazel when you come back from tour
you're supposed to come back with
laryngitis not an 18 year old man child
your last therapist gave me her notes uh
oh
what's going on i feel like we've been
arguing a lot more can you cut your
light off cut your light off my light is
off
david and i seriously need to reconnect
you didn't have to do this gig in los
angeles so the only
option was for me to give up my career
again you getting me this job at this
firm is the best thing that's ever
happened to me
it's crazy trying to be the new ari i do
not envy
this is assault how many years do you
think they would give me for murdering a
client because i think i want to murder
a client
the current chief of surgeon is leaving
i would love to throw your hat in the
ring
i'm honored i'm also really overwhelmed
you need to find an artist who will both
be out of a job
any artist that performs on my label has
to live up to my standards
time is money she gets started time is a
construct of the patriarchy oh lord give
me strength
hey what's going on boom david's new
assistant he says there's nothing going
on but i just can't shake this feeling
bam you have got to try these meatballs
they're insane
just fight this [ __ ] is it me or is it
highly inappropriate for a man to feed
another woman in front of his wife's
friends that's not even our business
gear eat your food you're right hazel
you have another chair
no when we agreed to give our marriage
another shot you made a lot of promises
that you haven't kept i am busting my
ass are you saying it's not good enough
what about
hiring someone you got us a manny hello
brie
jesus um it's pronounced jesus you
smashed the nanny maybe spanish jesus
was sent to heal your vagina and your
marriage
[Music]
a great philosopher once said life
begins at 40.
he's about to get litty ow ow
up until then you're just doing the
research i just need to know that you
got my back
i will always have your back at times
life is predictable
and other times it catches us by
surprise hazel we're surrounded by
children
we look like the chaperones oh oh
alrighty then uh we're gonna go home and
slip on our bonnets watch some random
crime television you know standard black
girl pleasantries
ari needs her ride or die [ __ ] clear
your schedules and suit
up sunglasses oh and seat belts safety
first everybody gotta really give it
some
get into the slack
[Music]
ma i wanna help you get me started
in the business the streets don't play
kanan
that's what i keep trying to tell you
but you don't want to hear me though
come on man
this is my story
this is the south side to make a queen
story don't call it a comeback
i've been here you said you was gonna
get me involved you pulled that trigger
you win it
[Music]
you can't afford the war right now rock
i ain't getting on my knees nick
not for you or no man
[Music]
you still in training time to put them
reps in let's do this
[Music]
you wanted to be in it you win it
say my name
[Music]
the 10 last welcome wagon has arrived
[Applause]
[Music]
so you're heavily favored this weekend
you think this will end your
embarrassing streak of draws
lord i've never been embarrassed about
having streaks in my drawers you know
it's all part of growing up
i got a question for you has a team a
lot of us ever won the whole chimichanga
not for 40 years oh no you don't come
through here that's fine yeah yeah i got
you it's like dukes of hazards yeah
or y'all probably call it the earls of
risk over here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i think it's time for these young fellas
to meet that guy oh no
let that's up
[Music]
all right you know turn birds start
touching your toes
they touch each other's toes what what
all that
how long was that not as long as last
time but nobody was hurt okay
people saying there's something wrong
with us not the way i see it
i believe in communism rom communism
that is
if tom hanks and meg ryan go through
some heartfelt struggles and still end
up happy
then so can we
[Music]
this is our turn to make history and i
believe we're gonna do just that
the family we're born with and to
families we make along the way
to richmond
under pressure all right let's go kick
their butts
butt on free works for me one two three
you